thank you very much for the introduction
and thank you for showing up in such a
large number
um it's my first in-person talk in i
think more than two years so i'm very
excited and it's also going to be the
first time i ever live code in front of
any audience really
so we'll see how that goes and bear with
me uh should anything go wrong but i do
of course have a backup um yeah my name
is kilian i am here on behalf of a small
company called inlinity which we just
founded which is working on using
explainable ai to open up new areas of
application for ai systems especially in
areas where black box models are just
not acceptable due to regulations or
other risks and i'm also speaking on
behalf of the xi studio which is our
innovation lab that we run together with
the university of ulm where we um
prototype and explore user-centric
explainable ai systems
you can find the jupyter notebook which
i'll be scrolling through and coding in
on my github which is at i
ionic solutions slash grogging lime you
can also find me on twitter
and
this github report should also be linked
in the abstract which you'll find in the
program
and so let's get started um
when we talk about explainable ai for
short xli sometimes it's also called
interpretable machine learning
it can be quite confusing because what
do we actually mean when we say that
um so
just to give you some definitions of the
way i think about this is that we do
have usually when we're working with
machine learning systems we're usually
faced with opaque models or this
standard black box model so we do have
some input there's a black box which
does something to the data and then
there's an output and everybody's super
confused why this even worked
and on the opposite of that spectrum we
do have something which is sometimes
called a white box model an
interpretable model or transparent model
and that's the idea that we might also
have a model where we know quite
precisely how the input was mapped to
the output because we actually look at
these
equations for example that we used
and i would argue that actually
all black box models are also
somehow transparent interpretable in a
certain sense because of course we
always know um what kind of mathematical
equations are inside of them and the
main problem is that it's just way too
many so we do have millions or even a
couple of thousand parameters and even
100 parameters
are usually too much for humans to
comprehend
even
even experts have a hard time simulating
such a model in their head
and so what can we do instead well
we can just look at another example
which we know from real life and that's
just something which everybody carries
within their head right so our brain is
a black box we have absolutely or at
least i don't have any idea how my brain
how my brain works i certainly do not
know how your brain works but
nevertheless we are able like to
communicate and i can hopefully convey
some information to you and explain
something to you and so the idea of
explainable ai would be to instead of
just giving an input and then an output
to also provide some sort of an
explanation which helps us comprehend
why this output came about
and
that of course sounds like a nice idea
and if you're like me a couple of years
ago you wonder is that actually possible
and how does that look like and
that's the question i would like to
answer today
but before we dive into that i would
like to
introduce you to the four principles of
explainable ai that have been published
by nist so the national institute of
standard and technology in the us uh
just last fall and um in my opinion it's
not really for principles it's more like
a definition and then three requirements
um but i find this framework to be super
helpful also in my daily work thinking
about this designing these systems
and they define an explanation as
something which delivers or contains
evidence or reasons for outputs and or
processes and you can already tell that
super broad right that could be a
sentence that could be a plot that could
be a flowchart
anything really um and
so
we already get an idea that maybe
explanations can take very different
forms from what we may be used to when
we first hear the word
and these explanations have three
requirements which they have to fulfill
or which you need to keep in mind when
you're designing them the first of which
is they have to be meaningful and that's
something which i coming from the
user-centric part of expandable ike just
cannot stress enough it doesn't matter
whether you understand or believe that
you understand an explanation or your
entire team of data scientists
understands it if the intended consumers
of these explanations don't understand
them or take away the wrong conclusions
they're absolutely useless so you always
have to put the users first and put them
at the center of attention the next
thing is more on the technical side
which is the explanation accuracy or in
other words you should not lie right so
if you generate an explanation it should
reflect what's actually going on and you
shouldn't just give like other reasons
for a certain black box decision but
they should in fact match what the model
is doing and then finally um which they
call knowledge limits in this framework
is something which most of you who have
been working in machine learning for
someone for some time will know which is
that for example even a machine learning
model can only operate under certain
conditions and usually that's these are
conditions that closely mimic the
training setting there might be models
which are able to transfer but we all
know that we then need to very carefully
check whether that's the case and we
have probably all tried to like push a
model to its edges and ended up in these
like really weird parts of the model
output where it's just statistical
artifacts and it doesn't have to do
anything with what we're actually trying
to to model
and with that said um what i'm going to
do for the remaining 20 minutes of my
talk is show you how we can create such
an explanation in the very particular
example of an image classifier
and we do not need a lot to do that
the only things which i'm going to
import in
at the start are numpy and the python
image library because we need to open
some images and want to look at them and
here this is really just for
transparency reasons i'm also defining a
number of helper functions which will
then later help us look at different
intermediate outputs that we're
generating
i just couldn't memorize them and i
didn't want to spend time typing them up
live
um and with that um we can start loading
an image right so we have everything
that we need we can just
load an image and then also look at it
and i've selected an image of a camera
it's just something like it's one of the
test images i've been using um and so
there was um
yeah quite useful to just to just go
with that um and then we'll convert it
immediately into a numpy array because
we're going to work in this array space
today
um
the thing to note here is so the image
has 224 times 224 pixels we have three
color channels red green and blue and so
this means that we have about 150k um
values um in this three-dimensional
tensor
and we can look at them so we just like
just by selecting like random
pixels um we we can see that these are
integer numbers they're between 0 and
255 so it's um the standard um 8-bit
rgb image format
and now we of course need uh an image
classification model and i'm going to be
lazy here and i'm just going to import
something from which ships with
tensorflow um it's a mobile net um that
is pre-trained on imagenet um so and
this has the advantage for the sake of
this this talk that it's not a large
model and will run reasonably fast
we can just as always ignore these
warning messages and then we'll go ahead
and um actually predict something um and
this is just the model.predict function
which we're calling there's also a
pre-process input function which just
comes along with that model it takes
care of um like rescaling the image and
that it's not it's not really relevant
to us because i mean for us it's a black
box right we shouldn't know anything
about that um and we just get the
promise that whenever we put in an image
we'll get a prediction out and the
prediction in that case um
is a vector of a length a thousand so we
put in one image which is why we just
have like one output
and then we have these um
1000 um additional numbers and that's
the prediction so for each of the
thousand classes that the model can
distinguish we have one entry in that
vector
let's just look at the first 10 just to
get an idea of what this looks like if
you've never seen something like this
before so it's really just a number that
reflects the likelihood for example in
this case that this image shows
something which is associated with class
0 whatever that is and in order to
figure out what class or what this model
sees
in air quotes in that picture we can
find out which index of that area
carries the maximum
has the highest value
and it turns out that 759
which is a number that you should
remember we're going to need that later
but
you might say well this is completely
meaningless to me and it should be
meaningful what we're doing right so
let's decode these predictions which is
also something that
comes along with that model so we can
map this number or this index in the
output of the model to some some human
understandable term
um this function was also provided along
with a model and it turns out
the model believes it's a reflex camera
which is
i would say accurate
and it also assigns it a very high
likelihood but it might very well also
be a cd player a cassette or loop or a
cell phone
and now the big question
why
so we are we have we have no idea why
that is but we want to find out and this
is where lime comes in or methods like
lime come in
and lime um stands for local
interpretable model agnostic
explanations it's fairly old in terms of
like today's xli methods was published
back in 2016 and really helped jumpstart
this entire
idea of extracting feature importance
explanations
from all sorts of machine learning
models
and um just to give you a roadmap of
what we're going to do now so like um
lime consists of six steps the first of
which is to segment the image then we'll
generate some samples from these
segments then we'll generate some images
from these samples
then we will run a model prediction on
these generated images and then we will
be able to fit a linear model to the
samples and the predictions and finally
generate the visual explanation that
we're looking for
and because we do not have a lot of time
let's jump right in
first things first we're going to
segment the image
and just to remind you this is what the
image looks like and what do i mean when
i say segment the image and why are we
even doing that i already mentioned that
we have like 150k pixels and of course
we could just like explain it pixel by
pixel right so which pixel in this image
is is relevant for the model's
classification decision but
for us humans and remember we want to be
meaningful a pixels are a very strange
concept but for example for us the upper
right hand corner of that image is
something which we um
which we would consider to be the
background right that's just like one
shape for us and so as the input to our
explanation we want to mimic that and
this is where we can use so-called
segmentation functions which are
available for example in psychic image
that's what i'm using here and the only
reason i'm not typing this out is that i
cannot remember how to how to spell the
name of this person that presumably
invented it
and this function allows us to create
what is called a segment mask
and so we just take this
function
put in the image and then we generate a
segment mask
and what is the segment mask you ask
let's first have a look at the shape
that's always useful
to see what shape it has and it has
exactly the same shape as the image just
minus the three different color channels
and we can also look at this because
i've conveniently prepared a function to
do that
and this segment mask
um why doesn't this work it's missing
the image
um right so you can see that it now like
marks all the segments that we have
generated and we see that it's a little
bit better than pixels but not quite
nice
and so we will just add some scale
factor and that's as far as i understand
really just a number and the higher the
number the few other segments
and of course there are lots of other
hyper parameters which we could use but
for now we'll just go with that and then
we see when we put it at about 300 we
see that like the shapes that are
selected as segments
are kind of mimic what our eye would
also see in that image if we had to like
draw borders
and finally um we can also have a look
at what the segment mask actually is um
this is as we saw uh an array of the
same size as the image but instead of
like having these pixel values um in for
each pixel it tells us which segment id
this pixel belongs to so for example the
upper right hand corner and all of these
pixels up here will all have the number
five so later we can find these segments
and this also allows us to find the
number of segments by just taking the
maximum segment id and adding one right
so we're starting to index at zero
and so we have 94 segments
and equipped with that segment mask we
can now move on to the second step which
is to generate samples
so why do we want to generate samples um
because we cannot look inside the model
we need to send the model some new
images and try to figure out like which
parts of the image or which segments
were actually relevant for the
prediction that's what we're going to
find out and so what we need is the
number of segments um because we will
need to randomly sample across them and
we just learned that it's just
the maximum number in the segment mask
plus one and then we can go ahead and
generate these segments by randomly
sampling
or generating first a random array which
has the number of samples which is again
a hyperparameter
and the number of segments
and then we will just keep the ones
where this is above
0.66 so like in every image in every
sample we'll keep a third of
the original segments and everything
else will replace in the next step
and then we have these samples we can
generate them this didn't work samples
is not defined because i typed segments
this looks much better so we have 128
samples times 94 segments and we can
just use
pandas data frames because they are nice
to look at
and look at what we generated so we do
have something which has 128 rows and
then for each segment we do have a
column and if there's a one in the
column that means we keep the segment
and if there's a zero that means we will
throw away that segment for that
particular sample
okay
next step um now we have samples now we
need to generate images because our
model understands images
and so we will need to
create images where we want to
turn every segment that's not in that
sample into into a black
area or into a black shape
and so we're going to go through so for
each sample in the samples first of all
we're going to create that mask which
just has zeros everywhere
and
so the shape has to be the same shape as
the segment mask because that's the same
size as the image
and for reasons which will become
apparent later i will just change the d
type to integer
and now we can go through and now we
have to look at each segment right so
each segment id which we have so each
unique
segment id which we have in the segment
mask which is going to be 0 to 93.
we will go look inside the sample
whether there's a 1 at that position
and if there's a 1 at that position
we'll go ahead and we'll flip the mask
from zero to one so everywhere where the
segment mask
is equal to the segment id right for
example upper right hand corner
everything will be a five um we will set
this to a 1
and then we can go ahead and generate an
image right so we will go images.append
and now we're going to multiply that
mask with the original image so we will
keep the original value
except when there's a one and we'll
remove and it will just turn to zero
when there's a zero in the mask and
because the image has this color channel
we'll also need to do some um
yeah we will need to add an additional
axis before we do that um
multiplication otherwise um it won't
work
then we can define this why doesn't this
work i'm missing an if
great
and then we can generate these images
and so we have 128 rgb images
and in order to see how this looks like
we can use the show image function
and then just look at some
some number
and so you can see that this is an image
where parts where certain segments have
been blacked out
we can do that again
i'm just like randomly walking through
and so you can see that we have like
distorted images and you can already
tell that maybe the strategy we're using
here is not the best so maybe we would
want to like always cover the same area
of the image so take into account the
size of segments
there are all sorts of things you can do
and this really depends on how your
model behaves um and what images you're
using
um but for the sake of this uh
presentation we'll just
take it take it
the way it is and then just move on to
the next uh step so we have 128 of these
images and now we can actually ask the
model what it thinks
is in these images
so we will run model.predict
we shouldn't uh
forget to pre-process the input
otherwise funny things will happen and
then we will put in these images
wait a couple of seconds
and then
we um the model is done predicting all
these 128
some images and so we have 128
predictions uh times a thousand classes
great this so far has all been preparing
things
for as an input
for the most important step which is
the fit of a linear model
and so what lyme is doing um is which is
also what makes it unique for example or
compared to to other to other techniques
is that it's trying to fit a linear
model around the original image
and tries to figure out which part of
that image
contributed most to to the
classification
and so we're essentially approximating
this a very complex a multidimensional
model with a very simple linear one
and
the choice of which linear model you're
using is also a
hyperparameter and we're using base
enrich here because it um it's
relatively robust
and it also doesn't try to bring all the
pre-factors or coefficients down to zero
which is what happens for example if you
put in an l1 norm usually you don't get
any explanation at all
um and just to remind you we had these
samples which we looked at above and
these will now come into play again um
was the second step that we did
so we do have these vectors and we what
we would find try to figure out is like
what's the prefect of a factor for for
segment zero for segment one for segment
two right is it actually relevant um to
have that so what's the coefficient if
we try to see what's happening
um and then um the second another thing
which i will not go into much detail
also considering the time is that we as
i said we're going to approximate the
model in the vicinity of the original
image and so this means that we need to
know how far away our samples are from
that original image
and i'm just going to be lazy here so i
will just take the norm so i will just
essentially try to figure out how many
ones are in my sample and the more ones
i have the closer i am to my original
image um if you want to be um more
meaningful
and also be more accurate you
what you should do is you should
actually calculate the similarity
between the images for example like by
comparing color channels subtracting the
images from each other there are lots of
things you can do but for now this will
be sufficient
and then
we can
fit this linear model
and
the x is easy that's just going to be
the sample so we want to know which of
these segments is important and then the
output is going to be the predictions
but not any prediction but if you
remember it's 759 we want to know why
does the model see a camera in that
image we could also ask why does it see
a cassette for example or why does it
might be a loop and then we will um add
the sample weights and there we will
just go just use these similarities so
the more similar we are to the original
image the higher the weight
um
i don't hope i don't made it didn't make
it typo
that looks good the fit is already done
and we get coefficients out and the
coefficients are just these 94
yeah pre-factors for the different
segments
um and you can see that they um
are like they're small numbers they're
usually around zero they can be negative
they can be positive um and this output
is what
we would consider to be an explanation
right so we know which segment is
contributing positively or negatively to
this image showing a camera according to
that model
um
but
that's not really understandable it's
also very hard to digest and so we can
also generate a visual explanation from
that and for that purpose i'm going to
use i'm not going to code this up um i
will use a function from a package which
is called visualize which we developed
as part of this xli studio because we
wanted to have a lime implementation
which is really meant for humans to look
at
and sadly the
original implementation of lime does a
doesn't do a great job at giving you a
lot of control over what the output
looks like
and so i'm just going to import that
render explanation function
here i'm going to put in the original
image i'm again putting in the segment
mask right because we need to know like
which segments to color and where they
are and i'm going also going to add the
linear model coefficients and then i
would like to have the most positive
coefficients in green and the most
negative coefficients in violet which
means that we're going to see which
parts of the image contributed to the
model to the image to the
to the model believing that there's a
camera on the image
and vice versa
and let's see how this looks like
um yeah so that's i think it's a decent
example and what we can what you can
already tell is that you in your head
also already probably start to to try to
like interpret what you see here um and
for example we can see that there's
there's something like uh
around this lens body um this seems to
be important this entire area on the
left so the flash also seems important
and that's actually also a problem with
these
computer vision visual explanations is
that they still require a lot of
interpretation work on the um
on the person on behalf of the person
looking at them and also um
if we now run this again and again you
will find out that like the the way that
this was set up here um you will get
different explanations each time and it
can be quite instructive to like
generate them again and then look at
them and you will always find very good
reasons why this is
why this is a correct explanation that's
really interesting like from a
scientific perspective um but of course
that's not what you actually want so if
we were now to really develop a proper
explainer for the setting we would run
this several times we would try to to
make it stable so that we always
highlight the same segments and really
go back for example to the segmentation
function tune the parameters of the
ridge regression
try to color different parts of it um or
maybe like normalize the coefficients
before before we plot it so um there are
lots of different things you can do but
um i hope that you got a fairly good
understanding of how like the different
steps that lime is using and if you go
out and look at similar methods you will
find that many of these individual steps
maybe in a different order maybe um
slightly like with a slight variation
but they all tend to reappear in these
black box explainers
and with that said um i'm almost out of
time so i'd like to thank you all
for
attending today if again if you would
like to have a look at the notebook and
also find some additional information go
to ionic solutions grogging lime on
github
i've linked the papers here they're also
on the github
and i've also um yeah they're also two
lime implementations one is the original
one which you can also use on tabular
data and then one is this
visual lime version which is um yeah
which was crafted and designed and
developed to be really um efficient and
to be uh and to give you of a lot of
control in the context of um computer
vision
yeah and i'm looking forward to your
questions
thanks for the question
the first one is what's the main
difference between lime and s-h-a-p if
you know that
yeah um so the the brief answer is
that um shep is a mathematically more
rigorous version of lyme
um so um if you look at the if you look
in there's a paper by the authors that
eventually published chap which is
called an unexpected unity among feature
important explainers or something like
that i think it's a 2016 or
2017 paper from scott lundberg and
others
and they um for example um they examine
lyme and for example methods like deep
lift which you might have heard about
and they show that they really all um
are approximating something which is
very similar and if you take the most
rigorous approach then you end up with
what is known as chap
in the
machine learning community
okay um then the next one what's your
favorite explainable ai library
that is difficult um because
my impression is um so i i did my phd on
that topic um and so i know a lot of
like these academic research
implementations and my feeling is which
we're also tackling um as inlinity like
in my startup is that there's in my as
far as i know i would be happy to to be
proven wrong that there's no for example
that there's no like psychic learn of
explainable eye or like a pie torch of
xr yet um i would say like in terms of
deep learning explainers i would have a
look at captain which is developed by
facebook for pytorch and that's i think
the first example i know of where they
really sat down apparently like a bunch
of proficient engineers and had them
code up all these algorithms in a very
consistent manner
but i don't have a favorite
one-stop shop
for explainability
okay next question do you invest in user
studies for example on mechanical track
to see whether people actually can
better understand models with
explanations
yes we do um that is um that's what it
uh what essentially my entire phd was
about um and that's also what we do in
this xli studio where we really try to
take these algorithms and also
look at different questions that are out
there and especially working with lay
users and to really make sure that
people um
understand these explanations or what we
do most of the time show that
explanations which data scientists
believe to be good explanations
turn out to be super confusing to
everybody and users don't like them
okay next question this sounds like we
are creating an explanation algorithm
and tinkering with it until it creates
an explanation that seems plausible for
us isn't that overfitting
yes and no because it depends on how you
do that so um what you um so there are
two two things and the first thing like
the first step would be to make sure
that it's like a technically sound
explanation which also brings in this
technical accuracy part so if we now run
this again we will get a slightly
different explanation or something which
is
widely different and so the first thing
to do is to figure out what are the
parameters that we need to always
generate the same explanation because
then then we can reproduce what we're
doing and
arguably get get closer to the truth in
a way and then it's really about taking
these coefficients
which we calculated up here so so this
is what we would do for example we would
make sure that every segment is always
negative or always positive but doesn't
flip a lot or stays very close to zero
that would be something to look for
and then we would go ahead once we are
happy with these coefficients and then
start to generate images show them to
users and figure out
do the users take away the correct
conclusions or not so it's really user
testing similar to how you would test
your um yeah gui applications
okay and then last question do you think
the explanations could also help as an
input to downstream models
sure in principle yes uh so i've never
worked on a use case like that but i
could imagine that for example if we
think back to the previous talk for
those who've attended where it was about
like highlighting segments of text and
then um
then then then extracting these
highlighted areas um from an image for
example i could imagine that uh that
something like um
being able to explain why your image
recognition algorithm thought that this
was like a highlighted segment of text
that this could help to just
to to uh yeah that it could help with
the downstream processing
okay and then
one came in and what is the advantage of
lime compared to rather than a if
approach to feeding individual segments
into the original model and comparing
the log-outs or the probabilities
so the advantage is that
depending on the on the number of
samples you get a really good
approximation um of the the model like
in a very in a space that is very very
closely um
yeah that is like or
in other words i mean what you're
essentially doing is you're mapping out
the decision boundary um in or
approximating it in a in an area which
is very very close to the input so you
have this
linear approximation and that's arguably
more powerful than just like randomly
sampling because we're actually fitting
a model to it
okay that was the question thank you for
your talk and for your work see you
around